Over fifty men and women, clad in red robes,
kneel before an unholy altar.
They chant and mutter indecipherable words
- words of cruelty and madness… of obsession
and sacrilege.
Not long ago, these were regular people.
Computer technicians, teachers, plumbers,
construction workers, accountants.
This was before they fell under the ungodly
influence of a new ruler.
The center of this makeshift place of worship
was once a normal school gymnasium, but it’s
now the home of a huge statue.
A humanoid being, wreathed in tentacles.
Its head is more like a squid or cuttlefish
than anything resembling an actual human face.
While he’s known to the cultists as the
Tentacled God, the beast they worship is known
to the SCP Foundation as SCP - 2662, and he
sits in the belly of one of their expansive
containment facilities, locked away from the
world.
But not for long, if his devoted followers
have anything to say about it.
This is their god, all-powerful and unchanging,
and when it comes to springing him from containment,
no tactic is too vile or underhanded to get
the job done.
Their mortal leader and high-priest, a man
in a purple robe calling himself Brother Marsh,
walks among their crouched forms.
He whispers instructions for the great day
of liberation that’s soon to come, providing
everyone plays their part.
It’s a plan months in the making - and one
that, if it goes off without a hitch, could
free their monstrous god into the world.
They would strike at the very heart of their
enemy, The SCP Foundation, when they least
expect it, and nothing shall stand in their
way.
How could they lose when they have a god on
their side?
But why did all these normal people become
violent zealots for squid-faced deity?
It all began with a dream.
To those who experienced these dreams, they
felt more like prophecies, premonitions of
the glorious horrors to come.
A red sky, billions dead and billions more
enslaved.
A dark silhouette on the horizon - Their Tentacled
God, holding dominion over all.
At first, it just seemed like a strange nightmare.
The ones who experienced it woke up shaken
and afraid, hoping to shake the images from
their mind.
But they couldn’t.
Every night, the nightmare would return.
They’d see the images - the red sky, the
dead and enslaved, the Tentacled God.
And after a while it would come to them even
when they weren’t asleep, eventually happening
whenever they closed their eyes.
Little by little, this scene stopped looking
so hideous… and started to look glorious.
They felt his presence in their minds, slowly
pushing them towards their inevitable future.
They started to realize that they wanted him
to rule over the universe, and to experience
the honor of serving him.
Many of them abandoned their homes and families
- leaving their friends and loved ones left
to worry that they’d gone insane.
In their eyes, they were safer than they’d
ever been.
They finally had purpose.
They were working in service of something
far greater than themselves.
The influence of the tentacled god drew them
closer to one another.
They would meet in secret, exchanging information
from the prophecies their ruler sent them
in their dreams.
They worshipped together, building altars
and idols to congregate around.
They performed dark blood rituals, involving
human and animal sacrifice.
It was when Brother Marsh, The Anointed One,
arrived to guide them towards their true mission
that things kicked into high gear.
Just three months prior, Brother Marsh had
been an office drone working in data entry
for a large insurance company, before the
Tentacled God invaded his thoughts with a
simple message: “FREE ME, AND THE NEW WORLD
I CREATE SHALL BE YOUR PLAYGROUND.”
Since then, he’d devoted himself completely
to the cause, quitting his job and maxing
out his credit cards to help fund his new
life’s purpose - infiltrating the SCP Foundation,
and releasing his inhuman ruler from its imprisonment.
That was the single goal he united the cultists
under: Freedom for the Tentacled God.
And at long last, they had all the pieces
in place to strike.
They’d finally gathered the necessary intel
to subvert the will of the most powerful secret
organization on earth.
Even the strongest institution is made of
people, and people are weak.
Unlike the almighty Tentacled God, people
could be broken.
The people in question were Kelly Thompson,
Sidney Levitt, Jordan Brosh, Dr. Juan Gutierrez,
and Gillian Larson.
Dr. Juan Gutierrez was a researcher with Level
3 clearance on the site where the Tentacled
God was being contained.
Sidney Levitt and Jordan Brosh were both Security
Officers charged with verifying personnel
clearance on site.
Kelly Thompson was a member of Site Administration
with research authorization powers, and Gillian
Larson was a research assistant who often
collaborated with Dr. Gutierrez.
These five were the key to getting access
to SCP-2662 and bringing their plan to fruition.
Normally, personnel dossiers on people working
for the Foundation were highly confidential,
but the Devotees of the Tentacled God had
their ways.
They had a number of computer experts in their
ranks more than capable of hacking in and
pulling some basic information off of Foundation
servers without being detected.
For the other information they needed they
turned to some good, old-fashioned torture,
which is often the most effective method when
you need some quick results.
Of course, while the cult’s grip on sanity
may have been a little tenuous, they weren’t
stupid.
While gathering their intel, they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were up
against.
SCP-2662 was being held in a humanoid containment
cell, and guarded by on-site Task Force TAU-9,
better known as the “Belligerent Bodyguards.”
These aren’t lazy, donut-chomping mall cops
- these are a heavily trained, heavily armed
fighting force.
Though the cultists had one thing that these
Foundation soldiers didn’t: The element
of surprise.
For everything to go off perfectly, Brother
Marsh’s plans would have to be executed
within a single day, and they were already
on the clock.
TAU-9 had been charged with tracking down
any new SCP - 2662 cults and dismantling them,
and Brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the Foundation tracked
them down and did the same to them.
If they wanted any chance of freeing the Tentacled
God, then they needed to strike quickly and
with overwhelming force.
The SCP-2662 worshippers were able to secure
the addresses of the five key Foundation personnel,
and station members outside each of them - including
one who could realistically imitate each.
They waited for night to fall, and broke into
each of their homes as they slept.
What followed was a sequence of ruthless and
efficient murders done in the cause of freeing
their god.
Dr. Gutierrez was shot in the head while he
slept.
Sidney Levitt and Jordan Brosh were both stabbed
to death before either even realized what
was happening.
Thompson, who’d gotten up to use the bathroom,
went down in a hail of machine gun fire.
Gillian Larson had seen that masked figures
were breaking into her home and attempted
to flee, but was caught and beaten to death
by cultists in her hallway.
It was a strange irony that people whose day
jobs entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies imaginable
were murdered in their homes by nothing more
than regular humans.
So far, Brother Marsh’s plan had gone perfectly,
with all five key personnel murdered within
a two minute period.
Next, the selected doppelgängers stole clothes
from their victims’ closets and were handed
the correct forged documentation.
The next morning, each replacement began their
journeys to the site where the Tentacled God
was being contained, while the rest of the
cult armed themselves in preparation for their
own part in the plan.
Nobody at the Foundation seemed to notice
anything amiss when the five arrived on site.
When you work for the SCP Foundation, more
mental energy is devoted to following the
rules that keep you alive than to memorizing
the faces of all your co-workers and each
one slipped neatly into position, disappearing
into the familiarity of office life.
But, infiltrating the site was one thing,
getting past the Belligerent Bodyguards and
into the cell of the Tentacled God would be
another thing entirely.
That’s where the rest of the cult would
come into play.
Heavily armed with whatever firearms they
could get their hands on, the rest of the
Devotees of the Tentacled God - Brother Marsh
included - would attack the containment site
head-on.
In the ensuing chaos, the five cultists who
had already infiltrated the site could take
advantage of the distraction, and break into
the containment chamber.
It was perfect.
They’d launch their attack from the outside…
and from within.
When Brother Marsh declared that the time
was right, the assault began.
A legion of gun-wielding cultists seemed to
spring out of nowhere and started shooting
up the warehouse that was a front for the
containment site.
The site quickly mobilized guards and task
force members to take on the sudden threat,
and just as Brother Marsh had anticipated,
the Site Director called on the majority of
TAU-9 to help repel the violent cultists from
their perimeter.
TAU-9 obeyed, leaving three task force members
behind to guard SCP - 2662’s containment
chamber.
They expected to be guarding the cell from
rampaging religious zealots seeking an audience
with their god.
What they didn’t expect was a group of five
Foundation employees walking right up to them
and opening fire, killing two TAU-9 members
and taking the third as a hostage.
While the war was being waged outside, the
infiltrators had found the Tentacled God’s
containment cell in the low-risk humanoid
ward.
Their hostage insisted that using him wouldn’t
give them any leverage - the rest of his team
would neutralize the whole group, him included,
if that’s what it took to stop them.
The infiltrators explained that using him
as leverage was never their intention - he
wasn’t a hostage at all.
He was a sacrifice.
The cultists of the Tentacled God detonated
explosives, creating a hole in the wall and
finally giving them access to their deity.
They climbed through and gazed upon him in
awe.
There stood SCP-2662, twice as tall as a regular
man, with ten huge tentacles emerging from
its back.
In their months of envisioning this creature,
they’d pictured it sitting on a throne made
of thousands of human bones, ready to dictate
its commands to the obedient liberators.
What they certainly didn’t expect was to
see the Tentacled God hunched over a computer
screen.
Still, gods work in mysterious ways, so they
stuck to the plan and began chanting.
They pulled out a sacrificial dagger, and
began sacrificing their captured TAU-9 member.
It was at this point that SCP - 2662 turned
and saw what they were doing with a look of
pure horror.
He rose up from his computer, his headphones
getting caught as he did so.
He told them to go away, that he didn’t
want them here, and that them murdering people
in his bedroom like this was inconsiderate
and disgusting.
The cultists became even more confused - why
wasn’t their god accepting their offerings?
What were they doing wrong?
They tried more chanting, and painting arcane
symbols on the floor in blood, but this just
seemed to make the creature angrier.
He told them, in a tone more fitting for a
teenage boy than a Lovecraftian God, to just
leave him alone so he could play his video
games.
This was seriously not cool!
The cultists were baffled.
They told the Tentacled God they were there
to free him.
He replied that he didn’t need saving.
That crazy stalkers like them were why he
turned himself in to the Foundation in the
first place!
Before the cultist infiltrators could get
another word in, the remaining members of
TAU-9 stormed into the containment cell and
gunned them down with surgical precision.
The war outside was already over - Brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were all
killed in the firefight.
TAU-9 didn’t look the least bit surprised
upon entering 2662’s cell, this was a common
occurrence unfortunately.
They had to deal with an attempted cult invasion
every few months, because SCP-2662’s main
anomalous ability is inspiring violent cults
who relentlessly track down and worship it
with arcane and bloodthirsty rituals.
The problem is, 2662 doesn’t do this consciously,
and definitely doesn’t like the results.
That’s why he’s under the voluntary care
of the SCP Foundation who keeps him amused
with video games and reading material while
fending off the deranged cults who try to
invade and abduct him.
Following the termination of The Devotees
of the Tentacled God, just one of many cults
who’d broken into 2662’s containment cell,
the remaining TAU-9 members apologized to
the tentacled creature for the disturbance,
allowing him to return to his gaming.
They assured him that it’d probably be at
least a few more months before something like
this happened again.
SCP-2662’s cell was repaired, and the Foundation
returned to its task of seeking out would-be
cultist emancipators, because for the SCP
Foundation, it’s not always about the anomaly
that’s being kept in containment, but what’s
being kept out.
Now go check out “SCP - 096 - The Shy Guy”
and “SCP - 087- The Stairwell” for more
strange and surprising stories from the SCP
Foundation.